I'm not the only one that is not happy
with CNN I want CNN to be better because
we all know what Fox is on one side and
what MSNBC is on the other side and
although I believe that the future of
news is online it would be nice if there
was one channel we could trust but have
you heard of this Jon Stewart guy he
also not happy with CNN and he told that
to Fareed Zakaria I want to get one last
admission from you please when you when
world historical things like the green
movement are happening they are spring a
happening yes yes you too I get my news
and watch these bathe all respondents I
was like that like I said a Google Alert
for Blitzer and then and then I just
wait say almost we have a CNN exclusive
tonight the Empire State Building is
blue during the Green Revolution you
watch CNN and appreciated the brave
reporting the reporters let me tell you
something the reason why I make fun of
certain aspects of CNN is to be inspired
by the brave reporting is to want more
good that's also that's that's all it is
you want more CNN I want more of good
CNN CNN is very similar to the doll
Chucky sometimes it's good Chucky but
you really got to watch out for bad
Chucky but we're all inspired by the
good stuff
no question next on but we're all
inspired by the good stuff I love it so
see you so yes I think most of us agree
with what Jon Stewart's doing and that's
why Jon Stewart is far more trusted than
pretty much everyone on CNN are you guys
with me on this like you missed the best
part of the clip what Putin what he
would Fareed says next it's like ah
thank you we'll try to do more the
goodies in it by the way the new story
is that Putin is trying to put the moves
on the first lady like that's literally
what he does next it's so amazing it's
exactly a cake yeah we have to pick and
choose what how much of this stuff we
can show sure but I'll just add what
happens next what happened literally
right after that clip yeah but are you
guys with me on this that eat look we're
all in the online news world so I
believe that online news
where you can pretty much get a lot more
truth because you know we're not
corporate controlled blah blah blah and
we're not you know this is done by
clicks you can choose what watch and all
that stuff what do you want CNN to be
better every time there's a breaking
news and they screw up the thing like
the Mosca thing that we just talked
about or the Boston bombing and they
speculate we're not gonna speculate and
then they speculate for an hour I'm
always like I want it to be better I
want to trust the news anymore and and I
don't know if this is super jaded and
and lazy and a cop out of me to say but
I don't even want to see CNN to be
better I just want them to be honest
yeah I don't care anymore about making
the any of these companies better I
don't care anymore about people saying
Fox you know be better be just be honest
yeah and honestly I don't believe you
can be impartial unless everybody hates
you so be honest you're not impartial
you believe what you believe
and that's great and the people who also
believe what you believe will love you
yeah so just just just own up to it
you mean honesty and media has Gina grad
gunman I don't don't try to have your
cake in youtube if you want to be an
[ __ ] be an [ __ ] but admit that's
what you're doing yeah when you say that
online news you can have a lot more
truth you can have a lot more truth you
can also have a lot more just [ __ ]
nonsense nothing so I think what Stuart
points out really well is that on CNN
with their resources they can have a lot
of really great investigative journalism
but they also can have like the ratings
grab and not enjoy the luxury of you
know we shoot this show we can edit it
if something bad happens in it we could
take it out there live all the time
that's the other end of that sort and
unfortunately it cuts a really really
deep yeah just for the record I'm pretty
sure in the year and a half we've been
doing this show I think we've edited for
content maybe maybe twice on something
that I really factually screwed up but
maybe literally a year that's supposed
to go this way yes other than that you
pretty much live to tape yeah so so you
alluded to this in the earlier segment
but it's just the 24-hour news cycle
just make this impossible like we want
these guys to be better just but because
they have to talk for 24 hours a day
they just simply the Chiron's get
screwed up they speculate when they're
when they say they're not gonna
speculate they that's the next thing
that they do always so is that part of
it that they just because they feel like
they have to just keep talking when you
put it that way I think it's it's mighty
convenient of us on the other hand to
sit here and and pick them apart when
when people do it you you want to sit
there and put a pot of coffee on and
read the comments this episode because
yeah we do the same thing where you know
we're giving our opinions we're
reporting the news we're doing all this
stuff and every once in a while we make
a mistake or we say something and later
it comes out that it was something else
so what are the media - well you know
we're not absolutely I not believe me
I'm not saying I'm above it but I do
think your point about what John's
saying about the resources they had if I
had those kinds of resources he wouldn't
change my ability to be truthful and and
try to you know spread some I agree with
you and I do think there is like a
fatigue that happens with the production
of live news and I was doing do you know
daily news and for a while and [ __ ] man
it gets there's definitely that instinct
that you had that I had to fight I'm not
gonna put it on anyone else and I had to
fight of like uh here's a story here's
how people who watch my show would want
me to handle it and here's the fat joke
I make about Chris Christie and all that
stuff and you really do have to push
yourself now I the more I think that way
the more I say you can't keep making
excuses that like oh I'm sorry my job is
hard a lot of people have hard jobs that
doesn't mean they can just take a mental
moment off yeah and by the way they call
themselves the most trusted name in news
so if that's what you're gonna call
yourself how about show it don't say
it's a relative term because look at all
the other news and news